but we start with breaking news this
afternoon and the education secretary is
coming under fire after mistaking the
england rugby player
maro atoche for the england footballer
marcus rashford gavin williamson told
the evening standard newspaper that he
had met mr rashford online but the
ministers aids later told the newspaper
that he had in fact been speaking to mr
itoje uh let's go live to westminster
and our chief political correspondent
john craig who's been following this
story uh and john this is awkward for so
many reasons
lots of reasons yes i mean the
beleaguered uh mr williamson the
education secretary is top of every mp's
list
for the chop in a reshuffle whenever it
comes
but this blunder certainly hasn't helped
him so what has happened here is that mr
williamson the education secretary under
fire over school closures exam fiascos
and so on has mixed up it appears two
top campaigning sports stars the
footballer marcus rashford and the
england rug and british lions rugby star
maro italji uh tipped as a future
england rugby captain that's marcus
rashford the manchester united star
that's uh maro itoji who was uh with the
light with the lions in south africa
recently as you there he is in his
lion's shirt so mr williams said he'd
met mr rashford on a zoom call um he
said that he seemed incredibly engaged
compassionate and charming then he had
to shoot off well uh later um uh mr
williamson's aides revealed he actually
met not mr rashford but marrow etogie he
has campaigned to bridge the digital
divide in education whereas uh
marcus rashford of course is school
meals food banks and so on uh mr
rashford responded in a rather amusing
way retweeting a journalist's tweet
and and saying this he said
accent could have been a giveaway there
it is there is the journalist tom newton
dunn's a tweet for he is uh times radio
journalist also writes for the evening
standard accent could have been a
giveaway now all this
uh in a week when there has been talk of
a cabinet reshuffle possibly tomorrow
talk of either demotion or the sack for
mr williamson in prime minister's
questions an hour or so ago the prime
minister defended the hapless
beleaguered embattled all those
adjectives uh mr williamson he was asked
by the labour education spokesman peter
kyle if he could put his hand on his
heart and promise that
mr williamson was the right person for
the job and is up to the job well boris
johnson said
the education secretary has done a
heroic job note the past tense of
dealing with a very difficult
circumstance in which we've had to close
schools during the pandemic so the vote
of confidence for mr rashford from the
prime minister uh but this is
embarrassing uh for mr williamson he's
either been badly briefed or made a
blunder himself mixed up two top stars
very high profile stars a top rugby
player top footballer marcus rashford
plays for manchester united and england
currently injured however and uh mr
williamson has uh rather uh
unfortunately for him got terribly mixed
up um marcus uh rashford's uh spokesman
has uh said that uh
mr rashford has written two letters to
gavin williamson first on the september
the first last year he got a response
after five or six weeks it was a cold
response he claimed
a copy and paste of a wikipedia page of
relief efforts the conservative party
have put in place since coming into
power from gavin williamson he wrote
another letter on the 29th of july
talked about healthy start scheme and
marcus says consistent asking those in
power uh collaborate for collaboration
more often than not his ask is rebuffed
his spokesman says
marrow and marcus are two incredibly
successful young black men this is
marcus rashford spokesman there's little
more they have in common whether it's
daniel rashford now that is a reference
to a blunder by uh matt hancock who got
his name wrong when he was a health
secretary or a marrow italy reference
the message remained the same put our
children first so
um what should we say sportsman one
gavin williamson nil perhaps